hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything
Annamayya manga and today we have a
review of a film I've been pretty
excited for ever since was first
announced being premiere and to be clear
I knew absolutely nothing about it going
into it except that it was being
produced by studio trigger and to be
perfectly honest that's usually more
than enough to sell me but as a result
let's give a trigger warning right at
the beginning here this was probably the
most trigger-happy studio trigger
production I have ever laid eyes upon
this film seems practically built on
references to previous works and as a
result I will probably be bringing them
up quite often in this review but Gurren
Lagann and kill the kill in particular
as I am most very very familiar with
them I should also point out that this
is a non spoiler review for whatever
that's worth I mean if you guys want me
to do a spoiler review then feel free to
make those feelings known in the
comments but if you haven't seen
premiere then never fear because I'm
here to talk fairly generally so from
the outset I should say that premiere is
studio triggers first feature film and
in that classical style it explodes onto
the screen in terms of pure aesthetics
I've never seen anything quite like this
because there is not a single frame of
this film it is not stunningly composed
with the unique stylings of this world
and one of the key instruments used to
achieve that uniqueness is simple
geometry premiere subscribes to crafting
a world to primarily out of straight
lines and if that sounds weird and not
so much like a big deal and I think you
really have a close to think about what
a world without curves would look like I
mean even the lens flare in this film is
square which I loved and while certain
elements of this world do stand out as
very unnatural like the aforementioned
lens flare it just integrates so well
with everything else as a general
aesthetic it actually accomplishes this
so well that it makes me wonder why most
animated features are so overly
concerned with any kind of sense of
realism rather than trying to craft
their own individual style but then
again that's what I have always loved
about trigger and they're talented staff
they are one of the very few companies
out there willing to take absurd visual
creative risks and have the proper
backbone to pull it off and make the
rest of the anime world look tame by
comparison now that isn't to say that
there are no curves or circles at all in
premiere there definitely are but they
are very strategically used as how I
would put it I guess for the most part
they act as accents to various objects
well they are made to deliberately stand
out like one scene in the film where our
main characters are eating pizza the
pizza itself obviously being circular
but it becomes a true focal point of the
scene due to that simple factor and
there's a lot more but the general idea
is that shapes are thought about
on my new Overland premiere and I think
this very simple bit conscious decision
allows for a flood of pure creativity
and that might be because one of my
personal mantras has always been that
restrictions breed creativity and
premiere provides the ultimate
restriction being the use of straight
lines and sharp angles 95% of the time
and so it results in design solutions
that very few individuals would ever
land on due to never having the
inclination to engage in a core
reviewing of the world around them that
really is the only true revolutionary
aspect of premiere though if you were to
strip all of that away you would still
have a solid film but if you're familiar
with the work of those currently at
trigger then you won't necessarily find
anything new to take from premiere and I
don't necessarily mean that as a bad
thing either however it is exceptionally
evident in a purposeful the premiere
exists as something of a mission
statement for trigger going forward it's
sort of like this is who we are hello
well type of thing and in order to
accomplish that it draws heavily from
past productions in every aspect of
storytelling be it characters action or
the plot itself and the most immediate
striking similarity is that of the
protagonist scholar who as far as I'm
concerned
his kameena there is no real attempt to
differentiate the two and despite the
fact that trigger have stated that any
similarities of purely coincidental I
think the fact that they're so similar
is the point and you know first it can
seem like lazy design you know going
back to the well of ideas that work so
wonderfully once upon a time but that
feeling is quickly dispelled when you
swiftly come to realize that the entire
plane of premiere is a gigantic mashup
the formal works it's like the staff of
trigger took everything they'd ever
worked on and shmoo shhhht it together
and with that in mind I like the choice
to have the communal light character be
our protagonist because he was a
fantastic gateway into Gurren Lagann
and he does exactly the same thing here
he's a loud flamboyant [ __ ] who's
passionate soul has the power to change
the world
who else due to the nature of his
established personality he is perfect to
helm a two-hour film because I guess you
could go with characters like Simon or
ryuko but they require much more of a
journey to develop as characters like an
entire TV series worth and that's very
important because premiere sets are just
under two hours and the story it wants
to tell does not allow the time for
exceptional character growth it requires
individuals who are going to adapt
swiftly to new stimulus and once again
Carlos lush Carmina is your guy to do
this rather unfortunately though this
does mean that the extended cast get a
fairly minimal amount of time dedicated
to them I mean there are probably five
characters in premiere that we
really delve into and they use the word
unfortunately in relation to the greater
caste because they all have exceptional
designs and personalities that I wanted
to explore so much more than we got to
like you can see their potential so
clearly but due to the medium of film it
just cannot allow for them to truly
shine the way a TV series would and
oddly enough the character I think you
can see this most clearly in is Vinnie
who is the rat mascot of burning rescue
the organization that Gallo and his
posse work for he is adorable in every
scene it he's in and you just know that
if this was a 24 to 27 episode series
that Vinnie would easily become that
iconic mascot in the same fashion as
booter and Gurren Lagann or guts and
kill the kill but while I do think it's
a shame that we didn't get to know the
extended cast that little bit more I
can't do anything but off a wild praise
to the film for creating a world of
people that I did actively want to
become more invested in I mean in a lot
of other productions I can imagine that
these characters would have been heavily
neglected in terms of both design and
performance in order to draw focus to
the primary cast by default but studio
trigger refuses to neglect these
characters in that aspect and I very
much appreciate that and while we're
here almost all of these characters do
take inspiration from previous works as
well so it isn't just scholar gray
Forsyte is another one that immediately
comes to mind because visually let's be
real he is what would have happened if
gamma gory and Ross you had a lovechild
it's just how it is
and I know the main female protagonist
seems very much like a mash-up of Yoko
and ryuko who also happens to pilot her
mech just like zero two from darling in
the Franks references and nods are
everywhere but I can't help but smile
every time I recognize something because
I have such fond memories of all of
these series I mean maybe not so much
darling in the Franks but everything
else in terms of the story this is
easily the weakest element of premiere
the story is it's there it exists and it
does what it sets out to do but it's
nothing special in fact I would be
willing to bet that if you could not
speak Japanese and you watch premiere
without subtitles you'd still be able to
understand the majority of the greater
plot like everything else the story and
its beats ro heavily from previous
titles so much that watching premiere
actually felt like I was watching an
abridged version of a TV series that I
had already seen before like it's not
that I could predict everything that was
about to happen but it all felt
incredibly familiar for the entire
stretch of the film although speaking of
predictability though like I said I
couldn't predict everything but format
is not a film that invests heavily into
the
your plot twists or any sort of
directional shift that you weren't
expecting
for example the characters with the
exception of maybe leo are all very
standard but I don't mean that in a bad
way it's more that as soon as the
character was introduced I knew exactly
what their purpose in the story was
going to be which may potentially remove
something nice for the journey we're
about to go on because I always prefer
not to know the destination but that's
just what it was and it doesn't
necessarily really matter because even
knowing all of that Vermeer is still
incredibly enjoyable due to all of the
work put into every other aspect of the
film they have to say that a lot of that
work went into action because oh boy
this film can get pretty insane during
its action sequences and legitimately
don't think I've ever seen action with
more attention to detail placed into it
than what is on display and premiere
every time someone or something kicked
into gear I knew I was in for some sort
of visual feast although what I will say
is that at times it was possible for it
to be in a bit too much like a lot of
the time the background and foreground
can blend very easily due to the
overwhelming use of vibrant color in
both of them and when this gets applied
to fast-moving sequences there are times
when all I saw was a blur of
incomprehensible stuff right in front of
me however in all fairness I should also
say that I had a splitting headache when
I saw premiere so that may have had
something to do with it the thing is
that even if I wasn't able to visually
consistently place everything that was
going on it still had me very much on
board and it actually made me want to
watch it again to properly appreciate it
there's a lot of master artistry to love
and premiere and I guess that might be
what my action complaint is there's too
much artistry to possibly appreciate it
all in a single viewing which you know
on the spectrum of problems I think is a
pretty good problem to have
far better than having a film which is
completely lacking and a slow to get
through at no point during premiere was
I ever tired of what was happening even
with the headache you know that's just
the result of shifting your efforts to
the realm of visualization in cinema
because you can have the greatest story
ever written with the most wonderful
characters ever performed but it's all
for nothing if you can't convey it
visually which is what films are visual
media and I feel like a lot of projects
may or they enough come to forget that
but as a result it is possible to go
balls to the wall with ascetics based on
a bare-bones story and archetypal
characters and still have it be an
incredible experience I would highly
recommend permit to anybody not just
trigger fans and definitely not just
anime fans I mean yes the high energy
won't be everybody's loaf of bread
especially if you're gluten intolerant
but I think the premiere actually
axé is a very solid ambassador for anime
it's a very good short condensed gateway
experience if you have friends or family
that you'd like to introduce into this
world and you know what even if you
don't go and see it anyway on the big
screen if possible because I suspect the
premiere might lose a lot of its full-on
force on smaller screens plus amazingly
enough it's a film that makes decent use
of CGI I didn't mention that before but
the use of 3d modeling even in anime
films is often fairly cringe and
unnecessary to me
it doesn't generally add anything but
with the geometric focus of premiere it
contributes significantly to the feel of
the world so no worries there but yeah I
loved premiere not as much as Gran logon
or kill the kill and there was nothing
earth-shattering but it was a highly
enjoyable experience provided by a
pretty phenomenal production company and
as always I'm keenly awaiting the next
project but that pretty much does it for
this non-spoiler review of premiere if
you enjoyed this video and the content
this channel produced in general then
please do consider donating to the new
world to view patreon because the
support of all the amazing people is
what continues to make this channel
possible and if patreon isn't quite your
style then please do leave this video
will like share or subscribe because it
also helps for this channel an
incredible amount and if you'd like to
join the fun at any time and please do
head over to my discord server where a
wide array of shenanigan tree takes
place on a daily basis and finally
please do comment with your thoughts
from n this has been the new world
review and I'll see you next time
you